this morning
voters in eastern Ukraine held a
referendum on whether or not to move
towards joining Russia but tensions had
actually come to a head in a very
unusual way late last night let me
explain there is a thing called the
Eurovision Song Contest it happens once
every year and is this simply the
craziest thing that you will ever see
basically 37 European countries
sublimate thousands of years of ethnic
and religious tensions into a series of
bizarre three-minute song testicles
lawful you like but you will all be
butter churned dancing in the clubs next
weekend chit chit chat churn it up
socha churn it up get a little bit rusty
churn it up last night's final actually
had Russia facing off against Ukraine
where their songs being voted on by all
the competing nations meaning that this
contest genuinely had more international
oversight than the vote for Crimean
secession first up first up
it was Ukraine whose song features are
going the background running around in
our hamster wheel and in case that
wasn't an apt enough summary of their
current political situation
listen to this
their song was called tick-tock
basically the countdown to an explosion
now for their part Russia responded with
a song performed by seventeen-year-old
follically conjoined twins featuring the
lyrics and I swear to you that this is
true cross the line a step at a time
maybe there's a place maybe there's a
time maybe there's a day you will be
mine
that is essentially an anthem to
annexation no you can't ask the people
of eastern Ukraine to choose between
these two songs they're both too good to
just go to war don't up the whole
continent should go to war again let
your up the tear itself apart yet again
the only way to stop this would be if
the Eurovision Song Contest work was
somehow won by someone so spectacularly
wonderful that it raised the tensions in
a heartbeat drag queen Conchita Wurst
took the trophy for Austria this is a
very big deal the diva won with the tune
rise like a phoenix this night is
dedicated to everyone who believes in a
beauty of peace and freedom
[Applause]
we are a unity and we are unstoppable
Colson
you just need
is it just me or between Conchita and
Michael Sam did the world did the whole
world feel like it became a better place
to live in the last 24 hours
moving on moving on finally this was
also a big week for Vladimir Putin who
visited Crimea for a long-overdue
victory lap in Russia's newest territory
speaking before tens of thousands in the
port city of Sevastopol Putin hailed the
incorporation of the region into Russia
as a return to the motherland listen it
is Mother's Day today and there is
nothing wrong with moving back in with
your mother it's just it's a little
weird when your mother has to send you
an unmarked militia to force you to do
it
[Applause]
celebrations didn't even stop there
Vladimir Putin will celebrate Russia's
annexation of Crimea with a specially
minted silver coin that's his image on
the front a map of the Crimean Peninsula
is on the back the coin weighs more than
two pounds that's not a commemorative
coin that is a commemorative manhole
cover are you sure you want to be
celebrating quite this hard Vladimir
because I hate to remind you but the
place you annexed was Crimea Crimea
depends on on Ukraine right now for 25
percent of its gas for 90% of his
electricity 70 percent of its water tri
mia only produces about tenth of the
energy it consumes Russia expects to
spend between five to six billion
dollars in Crimea but it's still going
to be a burden on Russia so Crimea is
going to be a drain on Russia's finances
and attention so congratulations Putin
in order to stick it to the West you
just adopted the sick cat of autonomous
roads
and you sing the cry million people it's
basically this guy this is what you want
Russia this man and the entire history
that his face represents and I just want
to be clear that this guy is having a
really good day that is what smiling
looks like in Crimea and why shouldn't
he be smiling after all it's his 16th
birthday frankly if Russia is going to
mint a coin over there annexation of
Crimea this coin might at least be a
little more accurate Crimea used to be a
piece of Ukraine but after Russia's
historic 2014 invasion it's now a piece
of history and you have a
once-in-a-lifetime chance to own a piece
of history about this piece of history
with the worthless desolate landmass
commemorative coin like the territory it
commemorates the coin is symbolically
impressive has absolutely no value
whatsoever
cumbersome burden for generations to
come on one side the silver-plated coin
features an exquisite portrait of
Vladimir Putin shirtless on a horse on
the other side
it features Vladimir Putin shirtless
carrying a horse if you're wondering why
there's no map of Crimea that is because
riding equipment doesn't give a
about Crimea which is what it says in
Russian around the edges of the coin
call now to order yours although on
second thought don't call now why would
anyone want this one to citizens of
Crimea coin is not chocolate on the
inside when Russia inevitably cuts off
fuel in a chip and storing the winter
months do not try to eat coin